alright welcome back everyone we're
going to slip right into the next panel
which is titled identities and I'll just
take this opportunity to introduce the
chair of this panel who is Jeremy spoon
an assistant professor of anthropology
at Portland State University so I'll
hand over the mic to thanks Andrew this
panel titled identities I feel very
humbled to be here I thank everybody for
this opportunity very excited about the
panel we're about to bring forward we're
bringing together different answer
mostly anthropologist but others from
different disciplines this panel
includes mahendra little OT who is
currently and we get to my right pages
here I apologize is a professor of
political science at Western Michigan
University followed by Chris about Santa
Kumar who is currently in the loose
junior professor of asian studies and
anthropology at hamilton college and
finally Jeff child's who is at Wash U
st. Louis and is a associate professor
so we are going to try and keep time as
tight as we can so that we can have some
discussion as well as the comments from
our respondents so I will now call up
Mahendra okay thank you for the
organizers for inviting me it's an honor
to be here let me briefly discuss about
perhaps what we're asked to do and that
what we have not been asked to do with
regard to Kamala an identity partly
because are probably political science
at a discipline and is research focus
probably hinders and obstructs creation
of linkages Milan connections even lrn
identity because it focuses on escapes
domestic politics within escapes and so
on so in that sense of political science
as a discipline probably has I mean
contributed to some extent in trying
away in the construction of such a
malign identity into a foot so with that
caveat let me focus on two things what I
will do is I will to speak about the
Himalayan identity and perhaps how
political scientists often times not
always but generally I mean look at
those issues and so on then I'll talk
about identities and how it has emerged
in the pod since it was formed a couple
of centuries ago and how it is emerging
now in a pod so so from a political
science perspective I mean we look at
States a relationship between escapes
domestic politics within States and of
course we also look at people the
mobilization attitude the behavior and
so on so from that perspective when we
see identity or we try to look at
identity what we often do is do the
people define themselves as a community
so in that context do residents of the
himala identified themselves as a
Himalayan community or him Allen people
and so on so if but if we take that I
mean a framework probably I mean we have
a weaker Himalayan identity in the
region and again partly because as you
saw earlier in the morning with regard
to the maps those beautiful
and so on those are those maps are I
mean within this map we have let up
speed boundaries and so forth so as a
result because of the state boundaries
the notion of amalah identity has been
weakened and even when we look at people
within those I mean reasons I within
those states oftentimes people mobilized
either against against the state or even
if not against state they often mobilize
within the states not always but often
time so in that sense even when we look
at people's mobilizations people's
behavior and so on many political
scientists often I mean do that within
those states centric framework not
everyone but I mean to a large extent
that's what people have been doing in
the discipline work one puts it so from
the perspective probably I mean there is
a weaker sense of the self identified
notion of we the Himalaya people and so
forth but that doesn't mean that the
himala identity doesn't exist identity
identity exists as other defined
categories as well because we can other
we saw those beautiful maps and we could
definitely say their life that my eyes
and they're like many people will decide
in those my eyes and they have many
commonalities they have many problem
there are many political opportunities
they have contributed significantly
perhaps to better their lives and we
could perhaps learn lessons from them
for other reasons other mountainous
regions of the world and so on so in
that sense I think the Himalayan
identity Milan linkages are very
important even though it may not be
people define local community define
identities and so on and I think
initiatives like the current initiatives
the yearly male initiatives and so on
are very important because I think that
is us I mean something slightly lacking
I'm about the studies about Himalayas
and so on and as we can benefit from it
initiatives such as this and even other
associations I Jeff and others are
involved associations of Nepal and the
modern studies who had been trying to
foster those kind of linkage and I just
wanted to remain share the good news
that we did organize to conferences and
put the conferences were highly and well
attended so in that sense there is I
think a market for those kind of
initiatives and so on and the next
conference is going to be held at Yale
in next year in March and so forth so
and those are initiatives taken by young
people I mean outside the region but
even within them in the region like the
issue mode organization and then I mean
that are involved in trying to create
such linkages as identities and so forth
and even the state centric I mean a
stretch tentacle state-defined identity
I think if we look at the European Union
experience with globalization with
weakening of state borders and perhaps
later on some kind of amine some soup
realm a state labor organization could
weaken the current state boundaries a to
some extent and perhaps there could
develop emerge a stronger male identity
even in the future within the notion of
the state's changing identities as well
so I think the reason me there is a
challenge and I think we have realized
that and people are working towards it
so probably the states may not be able
to hold that need and aspirations and
behind as well now with that arm of
course there are I mean the way we
define identities could have different
consequences if we look at the from the
perspective of self-defined community
perspective what that might mean is
perhaps because the people themselves do
as of now do not are strongly do not
define themselves as malin residents
already Molly nation or email if people
and so on perhaps last kill mobilization
along that identities may not reamers
that doesn't mean that mobilization at
local level
in the States and so on have not emerged
they have emerged and they are going on
but at least has a larger remodeling
identity best framework probably may not
emerge anytime soon but as I said
earlier that isn't weakened the need for
modern linkages and so forth now let me
briefly talk about identities I mean
with in Nepal because that's what I have
been studying and that's where I am from
as a native of Nepal and in the
parliament identity issues have been
very interesting in the sense that it
began to Inhofe centuries ago anaranjado
Conqueror some catnip pal and subsequent
saha rulers runner rulers punch at the
rulers and others tried to create
attempt attempting to construct a more
identity based on one religion one
language one culture and so on they try
to declare attempt to identifying a
polythene donation ill in the nation and
so forth but now after nineteen ninety
that notion of Nepali nation and Nepali
identity has been vigorously challenged
by Hindus well I mean treated as I don't
lower in the hierarchy apna pollination
the hour only pollination and other
Hindus who were horizontally excluded so
we have I mean challenge even up from
the Hindus of the MIDI she or the thigh
and lower caste traditional or cash in
this deletes and so on so the challenge
has come from English as well as
non-hindus
like the indigenous peoples Muslims and
so on so in that sense with regard to
identity there is a lot of ferment going
on in the path and sometimes that kind
of identity politics kind of a million
raises issues and questions among
different kinds of people at the popular
level as well as perhaps even in
academic level sharing with us this kind
of explosion of identities lead to
breakdown of the community of the nation
and including the state and so on but
what I would like to point out thank you
in this sense is if you look at me pal
and if you look at identity politics in
Nepal what we see is at one stage what
one can call perhaps the fragmentation
of identities for example now
increasingly people identifying with the
linguistics community the ethnic
community when they pass community and
so on having Google growing since 1990
and for example just to cite the case of
indigenous peoples in mid 90s or later
90s around 59 indigenous groups were
recognized by the state but since then I
mean a larger number of Brooks have
demanded get that did he also included
an incorporated counted and recognized
as separate engineers groups and so on
so there are now at least a government
state commission committee identified
more than 80 a such groups even though
that has not been public make public and
recognize that report and so put but
that what that shows is some level of
fragmentation of identity if you would
but I mean if you look at within those I
mean politics of identity in Nepal at
the same time
continuously as well what you see is an
integration of identities as well for
example the indigenous nationalities of
Nepal this stablished Nepal Federation
of indigenous nationalities in 1990 so
they are bringing disparate groups of
ethnic groups linguistics groups from
the mountains from the tribe from the
hills and so on under a banner of
indigenous nationalities and that are
similarly occurs with the Medici I mean
Medici list of different languages they
belong to different paths religious
groups and so on but the Medici
eccentric create a notion of a Medici
nation or Madea identity it is still
being congested but to a large extent
many people recite reciting in the
southern plane I do I mean agree do
recognize the identity of Medici to some
extent and similarly the same case goes
with delete the many different caste
groups of cash groups and so on
increasingly they are coming under the
umbrella of being a deli and so on so we
have both the tendencies at one level
many I mean groups of people many
leaders ethnic elite and so on if you
would are trying to assert the different
identities demanding recognition of
those identities but at the same time
the same groups of people are also
forming larger categories for whatever
reason we can go in to discuss about
different reasons being such as the
benefits of electoral politics if you
will organize into larger categories as
you might be more influential in
electoral and mass mobilisation politics
and so forth so there are I just wanted
to point this later I point out because
there has been less discussion of that
notion the integrative main phenomenon
and going on in Nepal
with the the fragmentation that many
people have recognized and identified
and discussed and analyzed so why have
this I mean different identities immerse
or are being asserted definitely many
factors at play the state has a role is
policies and of course definitely the
people the concern critical they elite
and whether the members within within
those communities accept the leadership
and the definition provided by the
leaders of the respective communities
and so on and to some extent to the
larger society how it recognizes a
refused to recognize it and sometimes
even portrays different identity groups
in derogatory manners and so on so all
these factors and these and many more
sometimes are the top of graphic nature
the territorial whether the different
groups are scattered around the country
or whether they are located within
certain territories whether they speak
common languages or whether a one within
the nittany group there are multiple
languages and so on this different
factors have facilitated hindered
and so on in terms of creating this give
different identities in part so in that
sense what this probably indicates is
that a lot of factors influencing how
these identities are now being leased a
circuit and we asserted and so on but
what we see is if we look at
historically during the closed polities
during the autocratic regimes and so on
you know what I call the attempt to
create a moaner ethnic quality was I
mean much more I mean successful trying
to impose the nation a fallen nation by
the state controlled by the dominant
group and so on but with the opening of
the policies whether it was in the 1950s
or whether it was it is after 1990s what
we see is opening of the politics has
given much more space to the
traditionally marginalized traditional
excluded groups and now and they have
begun to earlier said so now my one I
mean I would have been arguing is the
Polish probably from a mono-ethnic stick
is emerging and moving towards a
political icky and and this issue I mean
academic level at least from my
perspective is a positive thing but it
has generated a lot of anxiety within
the path and so forth and as a result
due to those anxiety rightly friend
wrongly friend or walk or whatever the
reasons has generated it's one
resistance among
traditionally dominant group whether
they help from the media academia NGOs
bureaucracies judiciary political
leadership and so on so as a result I
mean there is an ongoing attempt a
probably one which even a backlash
against some of these movement largely
in media largely through bureaucracies
and so forth but when it comes to I mean
the number game in terms of mobilizing
in the strips are everyone probably I
mean increasingly through electrode
politics also this larger number of
people that traditionally marginalized
groups though I mean separate into many
many I mean picnic and task groups they
are a collective majority and that seems
to be influencing pushing the policy
towards an emergence of Apollo ethnic
policy what can be deemed as perhaps
multi-nation state of net path so it's a
very interesting time in the fall in
terms of identities and I think we'll
continue to hear about this discussion
read about this discussions and analysis
and so on so with that I think I thank
you all for listening to think so I'd
like to start by thanking the organizers
of this conference for the invitation
for the fast and papers with a
presentation we've heard so far I had
sort of pictured a table setting for
this presentation so this is a I think
the first time in many years I going to
actually have something visual my visual
crush to work off of
goes so I thought I would start by doing
the classically anthropological move of
deconstructing some of the key terms and
the organizing questions and then I
would talk a little bit about my own
research and some of the connections I
worked on and so I really want to start
by asking a question that I'm still sort
of trying to figure out the answers to
myself which have to do with how does
one how should one approach area and in
a world or an academic world that is at
least in part post area right and so for
thinking about and when Jeff talks I
don't want to over generalize the
apology because anthropology itself is
still has a complex relationship to area
that the sector of the discipline that I
have training in then i come from i
think is has moved away from an area
studies focus and so the question for me
has to do with how can we lay the basis
for a new or renewed approach to setting
the himalayas in a way that doesn't
simply make that study another area in
the world of areas and so for me one way
to think about this has to do with with
opening up the idea of himalayan
connections opening up the connections
for some thinking on the mentoring and
so what I mean is in the context of my
own research I originally did my work in
omda and gone and gone on prefecture and
Ando I thought I'd be working on the
connections and interrelationships
between different means you inside the
Chinese nation state and so I went there
I sure to do that work and of course
Tibetans figured prominently there in
but the longer I stayed there the more
or my own interests and the
conversations I was having and the
connections I was making got sort of
dragged Southfork so pretty much the
first friends and informants that I make
connections with were returnees from
India so folks who had been in Don Shula
or even in comic in South India had been
there for some sort of turned up and
immediately hated it or got sick and
went back to China or that almost
immediately other folks have been there
for 7 years 8 years 9 years and so I was
I was surprised by the that particular
trajectory of return migration back to
to the PRC i also got to thinking about
the ways in which life had gone on in 10
years ago now was lived in a way that
was informed by how things were
happening elsewhere so there even those
folks who had not been to India had
friends or family members or had various
folks they knew who had travelled had
their cleared subjective feelings about
this and it you know they've friends who
travel to America and so I think you
know thinking about the Himalayas as a
spatial category or a series of
connections I think we can agree that
those sort of actual during processes
and intellectual motion intellectual
emotional connections that run across
the Himalayas to North India are you
know quite central to imagining of the
Himalayas where does the Himalayas
beginning but the question that he comes
where do we draw the line what about
those folks who have moved from india to
ithaca new york what about the presence
of tibetan buddhist arts religious right
in religious iconography in the
contemporary centers of Chinese power
does the delay is stretch past the Kouga
monastery to the lama temple in beige a
Jew weed and I think people can have
different answers to those questions but
I think we need to think about how
Lonnie you know what the rationale for
the answers to those questions that
you're that you're using and so for me
it's a question of do we think of the
Himalayas as beginning and ending with
the physicality of the mountains and do
we sort of root are our scholarly into
intellectual practices and journeys
there or do we associate it with a
broader set of connections that are both
geographical and also effective and in
that case Dewey is this meeting itself
somehow part of a larger conceptual
entity that we would think of as being
the Malloys and so as I said I don't
really want to to force an answer to
that but I do think if we are rican
sexualizing the the Himalayas as okay in
one hand certainly there's a there's a
physicality and groundedness an actual
geographic space but on the other hand
if we are thinking about the the
itineraries of human movement and the
connections are even feeling that
stretch across and beyond those
mountains it pushes me to a point where
I for I question whether the old
guarantees of area give us give us sort
of how should I put this if we're
thinking about traditional area studies
the notion of area itself is a guarantee
that a conference like this everybody is
talking about the same thing if we're as
South Asian Studies conference
regardless of whether you are a
philologist or a sociologist or
demographer or an anthropology what have
you everybody is talking about the same
thing because we have that guaranteed of
area and my concern is if we are to a
further the city of the Himalayas can we
approach this in a way that doesn't
have that guarantee that we're all
talking about the same thing how do we
know that we all you know are we all in
the right place maybe maybe not so the
question then becomes if we don't have
the guarantee of the physical geography
of the mountains at a particular space
on the map how then do we understand
certain kinds of places and cultural
concepts and human journeys as hanging
together how do these things come
together and inform this thing that we
would call Damon Wayans and so I would
say and again feel free disagree that
there is something useful in keeping
that open question as opposed to
allowing it to be resolved by the fact
of the Himalayas so that's my
deconstruction of Himalayas how much
time do I okay so the way that I want to
sort of put this into practice a little
bit is to say a little bit about this
the final question and the sort of set
of questions that get Sarah and Andrew
put before us so particularly how does
transnational mobility in the past and
present challenge understandings of
ethnic and national identity as commonly
defined and so I want to answer this
question in a context where you should
know a few things about me so I started
out as a Himalayan estai can remember
during my graduate school career and
sitting through classes on the
Anthropology of the Himalayas and
looking at various ways of thinking
about okay the relationship between
altitude and peoples and the
conceptualization of the Himalayas is
the interface and various other modes of
mapping something called Himalayan
identity at a certain point I stopped
being a Himalayan 'used and I went
a detour through through China
anthropology and so my view of this is
from the north slope which is a much
more gradual and imperceptible slope
than the south and so in this context in
this context the kind of movements that
I'm talking about are centered slightly
differently than the most the most
common kinds of mobilities that are
discussed and so I'm thinking
particularly of the the sort of return
migration of Tibetan attorneys from
Indian back to China thinking about that
kind of mobility in the context both of
other kinds of Sigma abilities and
movements in the Himalayas more
generally and also other kinds of
Chinese mobilities or even sort of days
that are shaped by by larger global
processes okay that so i will talk about
sort of my typology about those of those
movements in a little bit that's that's
a couple points about how transnational
mobility has affected ethnic and
national identity in olean region so the
first point is I think we have to
approach this question thinking about
transnationalism not simply in spatial
terms or in clinical terms but in
temporal terms so if we look at the
patterns of human movement and migration
in this area we can see that mobility of
various kinds both precedes the
formation of national communities and
has outlasted certain kinds of national
communities so we have to think about
the degree to which it's not a simple
case of the nation state proceeding the
transnational
which then moves across its boundaries
but that certain kinds of mobilities
exist in the context of shifting
political forms that then often reshape
those nobilities to their own particular
purposes and so one of the places we see
that is the efforts of the contemporary
Chinese state to reshape to that andreas
of Tibetan return as the journey of an
overseas Chinese person returned to
participate in the modernization of the
homeland so there's a there's a not a
necessary relationship between the
nation statement transnationally okay
that's number one number two I think we
have to look at the ways in which trans
hemline transfer layin migrations have
been productive of nationalist sentiment
so again this is going against the
common sense mapping of okay you have a
nation-state and we know how people feel
about nation states and we know how
nation states are bounded and once you
have those boundaries and those feelings
than communities can proceed out of
those and miss them or later them in
particular ways um but if we look at the
dynamics of the Tibetan situation and
even of the you know the prehistory of
the Chinese nation state we can see a
situation where you have a movement
itself as the as a key moment in the
production of ideas of a shared
community so to George Dreyfus and in
Kaplan other folks have talked about the
moment of exile itself as being as have
playing a crucial role in the formation
of a unified notion of Tibetan nationals
and so there is a situation here where
we don't simply have pre given
categories that movement across
boundaries then reshapes we have the
categories that
that come to have a certain kind of
stability themselves emerging from
certain kinds of movement that's number
two number three looking at the
relationship between trance Emily and
migration and nationalism I think we
need to question a natural relationship
ouch residence we should we need to
delink the idea of the nation from the
usual form of its territorial expression
that we find it it so we think about the
territorial nation-state a nation that
has its own the the classic Benedict
Anderson or tongue shy that where do you
find the nation you find it in a body on
a map that's defined by a line around it
and if you look at the Tibetan situation
that is one of the possible nationalist
alternatives that's emerged since
nineteen fifty-nine alongside that you
have a of national imagining that's
linked not two territories on the map
but that is linked to the body of the
Dalai Lama himself or linked to a
particular corpus of sacred and
religious or sacred in traditional
culture and so in that version of
nationalism nationalism doesn't
necessarily stay put where do you find
the true Tibet you can find it inside
the TA are and the territory of Tibet
you can also find it in northern India
or so in India or places where I did
have access to these kinds of
traditional culture so again this is
this is there's an uncertain
relationship between mobility the
nation's nation in the nation state okay
so that the point there is that notions
of nation themselves are traveling and
so when you look at the sort of
intellectual and cultural
cross-pollination that's occurred with
the movement of yo
Tibetans to and from India and the
conversations they've had about
traditional cultures uses and
nationalism its potentials and bring
those ideas back with them to to the
place where they started their movement
the the categories themselves are
getting scrambled so you can't
predictably find or you can't predict
easily what sort of nationalism a person
living in one particular place water
spout okay so looks like I'm so what
does this mean for an emergent focus on
the Himalayas well I think it has a
couple possible implications the first
implication is that if the lives that
these individuals lead between China and
India or between the west and Tibet you
know the various locations in these
larger networks are informed by
significant elsewheres I think we need
to take into account the the connections
and travels of ideas of Himalayan of
Himalayan asst in Tibetan asst and even
Nationals and I would suggest that as we
go forward with this it's worth thinking
about articulating a notion of the
Himalayas in which movement is at the
center and in which if if the consensus
is that an area study is what we want
that that area is outward-looking is
looking as much for areas of possible
comparison with other kinds of border
cross and regions or is looking for the
is keeping in mind the far-reaching
connections that go beyond the mountains
right so everybody in these mountain
valleys watching television
not everybody that many on the internet
using this technology or traveling and
so how do we combine a focus on the
travels of the Himalayas with the
groundedness of the right and so trying
to come up with some idea where we don't
try to simply drift off and everything
is in motion hey you know there's a pack
on that wall that must be the Himalayas
you know but we have a kind of you know
tension to the form is a kind of
grounded multiplicity that has to be
investigated as opposed to having it the
crutch of the area to fall back and I
was explained so I think often with that
well well that's warming up I can /
Ephesus with a caveat I'm totally
unqualified to speak about identity
simple reason that I never considered it
to be a topic that I wanted to
investigate as a graduate student in
anthropology 20 years ago it was the big
rage and being a contrarian I decided I
study something else but Sarah Nandi
asked me to fill in on this panel and
switch from another so i decided i'll
take a hit from for the sake of the team
and let's see what happens all my might
already tattered reputation might be
sunk today nevertheless i do do a lot of
demographic research it so i think that
i can address at least one of these
questions how does transnational
mobility in the past and present
challenge understandings of ethnic and
national identity is commonly defined
but like everybody else i'm going to
change the question i'm just going to be
a little bit more blatant about it and
here's the question that i'll change
into how does mobility of a present
challenge understandings of ethnic
identity among Nepal's Buddhist
Highlanders so with that in mind I want
to talk here about identity it has been
studied in reference to both Tibetan
exiles of South Asia and Tibet mids
borrowing Charles rambles term which
didn't really take off too well but I
okay borrow borrowed it and perpetuated
it but for a long time these groups have
been treated analytically separately in
the study of Tibetan identity and I'll
argue here that that's really no longer
feasible for reasons that will hopefully
become apparent so in the 1990s two of
this workshops participants sitting
shakia and Charles ramble wrote seminal
articles on Tibetan identity sitting
argued that in a historical times
regional identities monks Tibetan were
far stronger than any national identity
and so you can still see that as a
strong sense of places is still very
evident a decade ago I was doing a study
on kid on historical demography and run
across elderly people and try to find a
nut person and they say oh we'll go talk
to model dorje dorji from Marvel village
or go talk to lending Hamma Hamma from
valente Valley this sense of my identity
is connected to a place was very strong
and of course they were all kid on but
first and foremost about in a second but
as the sitting pointed out Tibetans are
culturally unified through a common
faith Buddhism and with the fall of
Lhasa and the flight of Tibetans to
Nepal in India that did bring a new
sense of unity for Tibetan exiles to a
certain extent if not to Tibetans as a
whole and after that scholars have
devoted a lot of time study Tibetan
identity and exile finding that all
sorts of strategies were used to form a
pan Tibetan identity which according to
sitting has been founded more on
anti-chinese I'll ideology than on faith
so in contrast the ethnically Tibetan
border dwellers of Nepal had retained
their own distinct identities are at
least until recently and with respect to
those labeled both here Charles ramble
wrote in 1997 there is a present no
organization in Nepal claiming to
represent the boat kids as a single
ethnic group nor indeed I believe is
there any sentiment among the peoples in
question that they constitute a
distinguishable ethnic category now that
might be changing with modern ethnic
politics in nepal up a new pre
work I came across this sign I don't
know if you can see at the himali both
hey autonomous state when I quiz locals
what's that all about they said i don't
know it's about a guy with this can of
spray paint you put it up there they
really don't know what it's all about
but in addition charles noted that some
groups of distance themselves from the
term botia the term that's applied to
them in a Nepalese state and evidence
for that is still found if you look at
Nepal's sense is from about a decade ago
I went into the new presume areas and
just took the upper VDCs and everybody
claims gloom ethnicity yet they speak
gutom Sherpa and Tom on which it perhaps
a little bit of a disconnect and I did
the same with upper moose tongue the
upper BDCs of moo song and you find very
few Tibetans lot of gue rooms some web
shows oven lamenting and they all speak
Sherpa and lepcha so a lot of people
would easily dismiss this data as
useless but to the contrary I don't I
think it's very interesting because it
opens up all sorts of questions about
why people self-identify in a certain
way and so I asked my friends in New pre
you know what you tell the census takers
and they said well we did that too
because we don't want to be labeled
botia we don't want to be put on the
lower rungs of society so I asked them
the same questions well how would you
self-identify I would ask them what is
your ethnicity meeting in Tibetan they
say well we're Tibetans what language
you speak we're to balance so given that
they do have a close identification with
Tibetan so why haven't we seen some
convergence across the northern
Himalayas of identity so Charles
referring back to his article again he
felt that it was a combination of
linguistic differences cultural
differences Geographic barriers limited
economic exchanges going kind of across
the Himalayas a lot going up and down
but not across with these valleys and
that was basically pre-empting the
formation of a pan Tibetan identity
amongst these communities and he argued
that the tent
unity provided by Buddhism as a rallying
point and quoting him was opposed by
close attachment to a limited territory
that found expression in cults of local
gods and certainly there's a lot of
truth to that because where i work in
new breed of gamma quyen mount mana slow
is a real organizing point for people's
identity they think of themselves as
their you'll other their protective
deity they have rituals dedicated to it
and so on and so forth so Charles was
definitely right on course there but
things have changed and I think that
questions we have to ask now or change
because all of these barriers are
diminishing and being removed and how so
well first of all let me just point out
that we've seen it happen amongst
Tibetan exiles so it's good to reflect
upon those processes the regional
differences do remain somewhat important
but mainly amongst two groups the
elderly were born in Tibet and the newer
arrivals who were also born in Tibet but
have come out more recently but when I
was doing research amongst the exiles
and a lot of other people found this
those who are raised in the secular
school system d emphasize their regional
identities they socialize with kids from
all over the Tibetan Plateau and they
intermarry and they're not you know
these regional differences don't aren't
as important so when we think about the
school as a site of acculturation we can
see that it has effectively reduced
although not eliminated the barriers
that regional identities pose to the
formation of a broader Tibetan identity
so is something similar happening in
Nepal today the answer to that I've been
gathering demographic data in these
areas for a while and last summer I'm on
a really interesting project and we can
talk about you know how do I find my
identity as an anthropologist working
with the physical anthropologist is a
great way as we get back
boaz Ian roots of you know
de-emphasizing the differences between
the sub disciplines and coming together
common projects but Cynthia ballet Case
Western and I and Sienna Craig have a
project going together on genetic
adaptation to high altitude and its
impact on fertility so I'm the resident
demographer on this particular project
and I run the new presume part and and
Sienna runs the moose down part so we've
been able to get a lot of good
demographic data just talking about
Newberry and soon these continuous
valleys our geographic coverage is all
develop the villages of 10,000 feet and
above that was because the hypothesis
for testing about altitude but it's a
good sample site we got five hundred
households detailed demographic data on
these and here's what emerges if you're
not familiar with population pyramids
you can see males and females are
provided here by color on the axis and
age groups on the far left there so you
can see there's roughly 150 males age
there before slightly less and that
females this is a way of visually seeing
what the population looks like and as a
demographer I can say something about it
this is the de jure population people
who are born in the area and have rights
to reside first thing I can say is it
has a characteristics of a young and
growing population which raises the
possibility that we're still looking at
an area of the world of high fertility
and indeed when you see that large
cohort of kids you see that and yo we do
I haven't done full
till the analysis yet but just the
completed fertility of women in the 40
to 49 year old cohort today we're having
a lot of kids okay so things change now
when we disaggregate the population what
I'm going to do here show that same
population but i'm going to disaggregate
it into the light color is those who can
no longer reside there they're born
there they don't reside in the dark is
the de facto population those who are
actually in residence this tells us a
completely different picture about
what's happening in these communities
and to give you an idea these are the
percentages by age group and sex who are
out of the village who are no longer
resident they're basically being sent
away to schools and monasteries as far
away as South India and if you take a
look at the 10 to 14 and 15 to 19 year
old cohorts a very small bug well a
minority are actually being raised in
those villages the vast majority are
being sent out and this has to have is
some implications for identity because
if place is so closely linked to
identity how will out-migration shape
identity formation the idea that we're
to look at identity and see to it I
don't think it applies anymore I mean I
think we got to get away from that you
know kind of going with what Chris was
saying no as a special treat for you
people today I'm going to show you the
Moose Todd data which is so hot off of
my excel spreadsheet that is burning a
hole in my computer we've just gotten
the data cleaned up to a point where
Cynthia sent it off to me and I've heard
we put this together to show you there
is a age sex composition and once again
what are we seeing huge chunks of the
population are pretty much being removed
from that population especially in the
younger age cohort so again this is
going to have an enormous impact on
identity issues just to kind of compare
the two we see there's some similarities
I think the fertility transition in New
presume is just starting whereas it's
been underway for at least 15 years and
boost on out migration of youths from
New Prien soon where is with the Moose
Don case we've got substantial
households entire household moving out
as well and the destinations are further
away and more diverse in the moose thumb
case in the new pre case but you know
again I don't want to just say this is
only happening in newbury I think we can
see this all across the voice and the
more data that we have to show that the
better nuanced we can get about it so in
any event I want to switch a little bit
now and kind of make it a little bit
more personal here's dolla kid from New
free that back in 1997 I raised money to
get him a scholarship to go to school in
Kathmandu so I was at though I was a
catalyst for out migration I guess but
so the first schools i approached for
these ones run by the tibetan
government-in-exile and at first they
were like oh great we'll take him you
got a foreign sponsorship yeah great and
then I said and he's from new tree they
said well we can't take him he's not
Tibetan okay well I did find him a place
in a school that was a private school
run by Tibetan refugees as well and as a
matter of fact most of the schools in
Katmandu that cater to Tibetans are run
by Tibetan refugees so he did get a
place in it but what's very interesting
is that these schools are teaching a lot
about Buddhism they're also teaching
these kids who are not from Tibet about
the Tibetans political struggle against
China this is another site of
acculturation for kids who are not born
in Tibet so is that grew up he became
increasingly interested in Buddhism
taking meditation classes and a 2008
when all the the riots broke out across
Tibet he started posting on his Facebook
page all these support the Tibetan cause
type of messages which is really
interesting and that was not alone
there's been a rapid fertility decline
amongst to that night cells they're not
putting a lot of kids into the schools
and also a lot of migrating Out so
nowadays without these kids from the
Highlands filling these to batten
schools those schools were closed down
they don't have the population of
sustain it they're drawing from the
islands and it's a matter of fact from
our survey we can see that twenty-seven
percent of all the kids currently in
school are in these particular schools
and that's just from one or from two
little valleys so what we find then is
that they're learning new values their
new learning new values about what it is
to be a sabaton not just a new pre
person they're also thrown in with
people from dolpo from Moose tongue from
la lune tune from all these areas and
these are kids we have to remember that
these are kids they're not terribly
concerned about oh you're from Volvo I
don't want to know of you they're trying
to make social relationships and they're
breaking down the barriers of
regionality as they're doing it and so
last summer some of our research
assistants for from soon some from
newbury and it was very interesting to
see how they can naturally interact with
each other speaking Nepali their
regional dialects are different enough
that they communicate in Nepali but also
one of my research assistants she's from
soon her husband's from walloon tomb the
sister of another one she's from new pre
her husband's a Sherpa so regional and
Daaga me is really breaking down as a
guiding principle and marital decision
making and that's going to affect
identity okay but this doesn't mean that
people's identities are being completely
decoupled from their places of origin
and to quote Charles again sorry Charles
Andrew
highlighting you here but you get to
speak later today as well I'll sacred
geography involves doing violence to the
nature to nature by reorganizing it in
ways that are congenial to human terms
reference and in the traditional Tibetan
perspective wild territories are tamed
by Buddhist practitioners and they're
made into places that are suitable for
habitation and I think that's a useful
starting point to see how the processes
by which these youths are removed from
the rural environments from a young age
and raised in urban boarding schools how
they're envisioning they're continuing
connection with what has now become a
foreign and perhaps even a wild
landscape the place is where they were
born when you see these youths going
back home for visits they're clearly
uncomfortable in these landscapes they
complain about being bored how dirty
everything is how difficult is it is to
relate to uneducated villagers they
regularly deploy the term backwards to
describe their villages and yet back in
Kathmandu they're creating a different
narrative I idealizing their homelands
it's very interesting what's going on
there now so young people and from soon
for example now are at the forefront of
labeling their homeland as the Hidden
Valley of happiness the bay you came
alone and this is from their facebook
page when if it's soon valley facebook
page so you know I'm the Apollo they
said he will the valley of happiness
well what is the state of people oh well
David was talking about shangri-la
before well let's reintroduce that so no
mames a guy in know quite well consumed
he wrote in the Nepali times very
recently if there is a shangri-la nepal
this is it the Guru Rinpoche is said to
have met a fated here soon was one of
the sacred hidden valleys of the
Himalayas called Bay you'll place of
such tranquility and he can read on
there but I found this very fascinating
to see this happening and it's also been
picked up not surprisingly in the
tourist literature the a bearded
vagabond reverse that
with happiness and his chemo room but I
used to be well-versed in the hidden
land literature and I even started
working in newbury because it is the
locale of the hidden land and I was
intrigued by that and so the last couple
of years I witnessed this new connection
of key maloom wit soon not Newberry I
couldn't help but note that zoom is
rarely if ever mentioned in the hidden
land literature when I challenge my
young Superfriends including Sonam to
you know find some references that zoom
in this literature well they often don't
read Tibetan but they always assure me
my cousins a monk I'll get them on the
case and we'll find it yet I haven't
seen the evidence yet but whether Kim
alone is situated and sue more new pre
is not really the issue here and let me
just kind of run you through here
because I didn't show this before but
here are the valleys will put in new pre
and soon there there is actually a key
maloom circuit it's a pilgrimage route
that's not used very often but it does
eco compass zoom and newbury but the
actual hidden land with its temple is
situated right there in newbury it's
very clear but so successful that they
been at creating this image of zoom
equals key maloom they're claiming
that's what key balloon is when I just
did a Google search which is not a great
metric here but when i put in nutrient
hidden valley i get 420 results when i
put zoom in hidden valley and I get
19,200 results
they've done a good job so in any event
I think that it's interesting because
again it's not whether where the place
is located it's interesting from the
perspective of identity I think what's
very interesting here is that for the
zoom you it's coming from a hidden
valley of happiness provides these kids
with some connection to a homeland that
sites you know being kind of a rough and
tumble place on the outside is actually
a very special place and so they're
taming the landscape framed as backward
in the discourse of development by
drawing upon this Buddhist utopian
vision and in doing so they're
presenting it as a place whose
inhabitants are the epitome of the
Tibetan exceptionalism that they've been
learning in these schools that they're
innately spiritual nonviolent
conscientious stewards of a Christian
environment it's precisely that image
that they're learning in school and it's
been promoted by Tibetan exiles so they
may not want to live and zoom but it's
going back to Charles terms at very
least I want to present their homeland
in ways that are congenial to human
terms of reference okay I'm going to run
out of time very quickly so I have to
dash ahead but I did want to say
something about keep oops these welfare
associations which are forming right
left and center traditionally this was a
way for people to fray costs of funerals
and weddings are very expensive so you
get a grouping of families together that
help each other out and they would have
even white registers and it's a great
example of balanced reciprocity whatever
another family gives you you record that
when they have a wedding you have to
give exactly back what they get I gave
to you but the evolution of this that
we're seeing through time is that they
used to be village-based is so
creations as tibetans moved from the
highlands in to Katmandu we saw some
spring up and now they're becoming
international association so it went
from being like chirp association of
nepal and the new pre association which
still is based in kathmandu to now we've
got the walloon community of North
America United shirts Association dolpo
society all international societies and
no other all referring their identity
you're pegging it to Buddhism but again
these are very regional things and it's
charles road again about what Hugh's
first noticing these their concerns were
regional but now as they branch out into
international community's i just want to
look at the yomo key duke very quickly
here to see what they say on their
website first of all the main objectives
is to establish a strong strong support
system when you look at that you can
refer to Massie's theory of cumulative
causation how some people will form a
bridge at and that reduces the cost for
other migrants from that place to come
and settle in this area this particular
part of New York but also they are doing
some identity maintenance to preserve
preserve and promote yomo culture
they're fulfilling some of the
traditional key Duke functions but
here's another interesting point it
looks like they want to link up with
like-minded organizations what are those
those are other key boots from the
Himalayas and so we can see perhaps the
formation or the nascent formation of a
pan Tibetan identity here you look at
the MU steinke Duke in the USA well they
not too long ago they had their stand in
solidarity with Tibet day ki bhook
looking at a broader to that an issue
also this one I don't think it went very
far but you did have become some Tibetan
calm which is comprising
members an executive board is all these
regional key Dukes that were coming
together to promote a common cause and
by the way website powered by Free Tibet
us okay so what does this all mean I'm
not entirely sure again this is not my
real topic but a couple points I want to
make here number one with respect to
questions of identity I think we have to
focus on the youths and the educated use
these are going to be the real drivers
of identity issues as we move into the
future their mobile but also they're
communicating across communities they
have friends from all these different
communities they're going to be the real
drivers of the identity formation second
of all we have to move beyond are
superficial statements like people are
more mobile today and actually start to
get a quantitative sense of what's going
on I mean this is a huge depopulation
issue we're looking at that is going to
impact everything from environmental
sustainability to household economic
practices to labor allocation within the
household so we can no longer look at
identities in a general himalayan way
like they're done in development this
course a lot as these are rural poor
farmers we can't look at them that way
anymore that's not what they are there's
the movement to the Gulf their wage
laborers they're making their money off
with yards of guru in Tibet seventy-five
percent of their household wages come
from non farm labor so we can't look at
them as for rural subsistence farmers
and also just a one last point about our
genetic research what if our genetic
research actually says these people are
Google's what we do then with identity
well thank you very much everyone thank
you especially our panelist for three
very serious papers that are
intellectually provocative and
methodologically important I just want
to remind us I think we should start by
saying what did they say well majandra
know what he reminded us that a
political science view of identity sees
both fragmentation and integration
happening and he also reminded us that
that looks at this within the context of
a state and temporarily he's reminding
us that in their power this process is
changing very fast and then when we look
at chris's paper he's he's focusing on
this word of mobility trans mobility and
asking us where the area is when we want
to do area studies how do we do area
studies when it's centered on movements
and on connectivity and the word you use
trajectories the word in the title of
this conference itineraries and then we
just heard Jess tour-de-force where he
manages to get statistics even into a
discussion of identity and very well to
that we need to look at the ground
reality of what are the shapers what are
the actual constituents the actual human
bodies on the ground that actually are
the sources the forces and then the
holding containers of identity if I
can't put it like that he didn't he
didn't shake his head so I I think we
some general questions can come out of
this I think we looking overall not
specifically here at a general tension
between the social scientists view of
the subject and the viewer let's say
other not just disciplines other
approaches of the subject philologist
the cultural studies the religious
studies the tippet rogers we're looking
at the general tension in all our
discussions here between the view of the
subject does special and the view of the
subject as ordinary is our study there
to find commensurable similarities
between people in a sense as as multiple
variants what Jeffrey Samuel earlier
referred to as what are we looking
should we be looking at people in their
commonalities with the peoples in
sub-saharan Africa or that other view
that Jeffrey talked about that the idea
of these people as as part of a culture
that's offset exceptional interest of
those of us who study it so revisiting
their what Jeffrey brought to us this
morning I think we have to try to keep
this in mind we're not in a position to
rule out other option here where we see
these three important papers that focus
on the subject in terms of commonalities
with other kinds of subject other
peoples who move who migrated who live
in places who leave their elderly behind
who seek for cash income and so on
there's a sudden is it's hugely
important that we do that but the risk
is a kind of reductionism and as we all
know from many years of critique the
risk of the opposite approach it is a
kind of exceptionalism so between these
two we have to find some kind of
productive interaction between these two
views we also have to find a productive
interaction between this very
problematic question of the outside and
the inside if I complete it like that
and here I'm thinking about the marginal
and the center I suppose when we think
of the larger Himalayan area whatever we
mean by that and I
you've heard already we tend to be
focusing on tibet nepal sometimes bhutan
we're looking only at a fragment but
even within that fragment we tend to
focus on the area around the mountain
the southern mountain fringe of this
larger area if we remember what peter
produce said this morning that we can
think of shining in some way as the
northern extremity of this area we tend
to look more at this southern area the
area around the mountains where we do
see these processes of fragmentation
that all our three panelists spoke about
so eloquently this process of movement
and particularly transnational movement
in fact we have at least two of my
exceptional students here who are
exactly from the places that jeff has
been talking about who know about it in
much more detail in there lived bodies
even than jeff can explain to us but in
fact if we think just about that
population millions of those people are
living in the northern parts of the
tibetan plateau or the eastern parts of
the Tibetan Plateau particularly
actually closer to Xin probably closer
to where Chris did his research done and
what we find it difficult somehow to
introduce those people into the same
conversation this is the historic
problem of should say Nepali studies
trying to talk to shall we call it
loosely Tibetan studies as it evolved
after 1980s listen if partly to do with
access where we we can call us something
collective where we get permission to go
and research there's a strange thing
because many scholars are Chinese here
because we mainly have vball but he can
go to any of these places any Chinese
scholar can go to any of these places
but we tend to be giving preference to
English and western languages most
english language we tend not to be
reading the literature of our Chinese
counterparts and collaborators who we
thought about earlier who are talking
about the peoples in there so how can we
create a more a more inclusive
discussion that goes across this area
rather than the areas where we because
of our linguistic preferences and habits
and historic dominations in the case of
English have access to and again are we
somehow distorting or giving a special
preference to the mobility factor that
goes towards the west or towards the
south where we have that access we meet
these people all the time because a
particular subgroup we are because we're
not Chinese scholars in China for
example or in Pakistan or Bangladesh how
can we extend that thinking to think
about people who we don't meet who go in
other directions the mobility for
example to lando or to Chengdu or to
Beijing or to Guangzhou or high none
this may be may be important and maybe
if we ask that question I'm not sure
necessarily that mobility will be the
issue and I'm also not sure as I think
several you mentioned Chris in
particular that is not necessarily a new
issue it's a prehistory we know that
these areas are marked as being between
major centralizing States historically
over thousands of years trading routes
and so on that so there's a certain need
to think in the long term about these
mobility questions and to think of what
isn't about mobility and what isn't cut
about coming towards the areas which we
in our particular group have preference
for Thank You Jay aside from whether you
give PowerPoint master classes
I'm intrigued by the idea that they say
that booty can gain a traction now in
this more connected and international
climate of dispersal that it never had
within the nation state itself but the
Indian government and this is a question
two colleagues Romania classifies people
who are Tibet laid across the Himalayan
region east and west similars as audit
or butea so both shaking his hand but on
the Indian linguistic census that I have
access to our says the people along the
top northwestern fringe and the north
eastern fringe all Bhatia so does that
state classification of these very
distinct communities somehow create a
wider sense of Batiatus or not and its
really an open question I responded it's
complicated of course the essen on them
to use differently that may be a
linguistic classification and it's
certainly a popular word it's not used
by the Indian government in classifying
people say in the census or terms of
ethnicity a lot of actors down in
dehradun places like that will resist
the term or when you get up into the
body our bellies it's not such a big
deal internally they use the names of
the five so-called my house and so
they're SME no March I told ya donia it
said so it's pretty complicated but it's
not I mean a navy in some places a
linguistic Kermit actually because of
the activists I think it's a term of the
government would avoid thank you I'll
sleep just very very grateful
Boateng you notice and so I coalesce
around the reason the sofa and the
reason I should add that the so-called
for tia is one of the main reasons that
the Indian he's Indian groups don't
sometimes resist name is they do not
want to be identified with as Tibetans
or Buddhism because they're very much
trying to assimilate into main
mainstream Hindu party society so that's
really when wisely thank you please
question who's got some right over there
I wonder they're so a couple things that
if we're deconstructing categories as
well things like migration hey then I
mean migration can take so many
different forms that these kids that are
in school I mean how many how many weeks
of the year do you have to be in a place
to have it be an important part of your
in a sort of your habit us your
experience of if when you go out and
when you come back as opposed to when
you go out and stay out if and
increasingly a lot of these migrants are
our they're part of the family's back
and part of the family is out and so the
the one of the you know you put have a
bunch of those facebook images but the
number of them that are miss you love
you see you soon I mean all these very
very of employment expressions of
separation so that you know some of the
the ideas about what migration means and
again the question of where you're
talking from if you were talking from
western China to eastern China maybe
nobody would call you a migrant any more
than if you move from Boston two
California not Boston two California it
but somewhere else I have the questions
of what migration work migration means
and sort of somehow seeing if if we
would learn something more informative
if we thought about what the different
kinds of migration would be and it's
obviously the same question about
identity there's a kind of politically
deployable group identity that is so
visible on the Nepalese seeing these
days and then there's you know then
there are other things about what you
call yourself and
I think the things that you found with
being calling yourself girl but speaking
come on or and those I think mark found
those things in insuk in as well now
instead of trying to erase the confusing
asst in that may be enjoying it a little
bit more maybe exploring a little bit
more so you find out that you know
nobody will call themselves beaute even
though that may be a really solid
sailing of identity figuration for who
you rescue and who you don't ask you and
who you despise I mean you don't despise
and so on so I just you know those all
of each of those terms I think actually
I deconstructing them at this point a
lot more would be a lot it would be a
very interesting project and I wonder
things like in your migration literature
how seasonal is it how permanent is it
how right and some of these identity
politician leaders how much how has
their self representation of identity
changed I was just trying to look on the
nefyn web page to see one point they did
have Forte listed as but it was only it
was only one or two little areas and it
was a clear how they identified it but
I'm not sure exactly what the question
there is except to say maybe respond in
terms of how useful is it to think about
identity as more than one thing and
migration is
before our panelists respond we're going
to take some more questions please maybe
raise your own failure I just wanted to
echo what Catherine is saying i love
your paper Jeff and what I like about it
what you call you sort of called into
question a lot of easy assumptions you
took one easy assumption after another
new tried to question that that was all
good but then you made an assumption i
think which i would like a question you
said several times in light of this
migration you kept saying look with all
of this migration it must things
identity must really be changing and I
wonder of course well yes I guess it
must but the fact that that someone may
be raised to be going to school far away
or spend years separated from his or her
native place doesn't necessarily may
result in a strengthening of local
identity and it seemed to me that the
point you were making it's a vocal
identity made some holiday we can not
necessarily could work the other way
around let's take another question over
here please I caught a question for Jeff
child and it's very interesting for you
talk about a key tool you know in Tibet
easily share to happiness at bethany's
together people are very serious in
terms of you to get organized ation it's
a very traditional because no it's
organized in on the principle of career
your gender and also your hobby and
something else and according to your
study are there some new function of the
chest transnational sharkey do no you
just mention about some shark III united
states do they have some new function
like economical social on the cultural
thank you thanks name atashi we had a
question over here too yep i was
wondering whether it to what degree it
would be helpful to think about other
mountainous areas that historically
were sending huge numbers of my poor
migrants out the Alpine region also
split into many different nation state
units there's all a history there that
might be enlightening and it's always
seemed to me that being away from a
stigmatized place makes you proud of it
than you were when you were there so
Appalachians out of Appalachian are
likely to be more proud of Appalachia as
our Irish out of Ireland proud of being
Irish so there's something about
distance from the stigmatized identity
to take up the question of Appalachia
just ever so briefly it's astounding the
degree to which let's say in the Civil
War the since the people highest up in
the Appalachians didn't have slaves they
also deserted it much higher rates than
any other parts of the Confederacy and
in fact you can correlate altitude with
desertion almost perfectly we have the
statistics for that the it and these
places in the hills have more in common
with one another in many respects
ecologically in terms of trade in terms
of subsistence modes in terms of illegal
distilling and they had with people in
the valleys right through all of these
different different states and I thought
that the most of these people of course
left Appalachian just as there were I
think was a Detroiter Cleveland was the
second largest holy city after a Warsaw
so it was Detroit essentially an
Appalachian city for a long time and
yeah they took along their bluegrass
music
took along parts of the cuisine and so
on so they became a kind of diasporic it
seems to me the Appalachian identity has
been formed more in the Diaspora then it
has been formed in Appalachia itself but
the general point I wanted to make is
that it would help us to look at other
sophisticated deep analytical histories
of other poor mountain areas that are
export labor in order to sensitizes to
some useful questions with respect to
that in lives let's give our panelists a
chance to respond Fred I agree but in a
20-minute format I couldn't break down
migration into temporary semi-permanent
seasonal and so forth all those
categories matter I agree completely so
in future work it will refer to that bow
you're right i'm guilty of an assumption
i will restate that as a hypothesis
that's worthy of investigation began
you're right that's an assumption that
i'm making it might be right it might be
wrong but i don't know i have
actually investigated this soils I will
restate that as a hypothesis according
to keith oops yes they are serving you
functions abroad and again that's why i
refer to Massie's cumulative causation
bottle of migration because i think it
is a facilitator or further migration by
connecting those people in the homeland
with a potential migration destination
and that is not a traditional cubic
function and your comment i'm already
doing the literature review on the lv on
so and bob netting who is one of my
heroes and anthropology's have written
about these japan's mountain areas have
depopulated it's interesting to hear the
Appalachian case I'll look into that as
well because it is this is not a unique
phenomenon every mountain area in the
world in an area that has become rapidly
developed as depopulated very vascular
as well so that's all say and I just
like to two microphones um your spinal
go further to Katherine because i think
it's a it's a very good suggestion to
specify different throats of migration i
think we also have to put migration
along side other kinds of movement and
think about what kinds of movement we
want to include in waiting connections
and so the one that has been occurring
to me is what do we make of sort of the
massive growth of chinese backpacker
tourism chamdo also to other parts of
here so you also you been to places like
Nepal is that something that is a dweet
conceptualize that is inside or outside
it son for the complex let's take a few
more questions please j
yeah I'm sorry Robert go ahead right
please yes yes yes thank you throughout
the whole panel I've been thinking of
one person who's autobiographical works
I've read it on the intense and rapist
was born in wookie not in 1646 and his
life story brings up many of the issues
that all previous program about he would
say he was a rape up top yogen by
profession you might say but he came
about through great difficulty he had
two trips essential to that one was
forced because he was went up over the
top of the plateau hooked up with some
central Tibetan yoga nice if n was
kidnapped by them taken eastward as sold
to a Nepalese merchant coming back on
from Lhasa and it was taken to a Hannah
do and then escapes
great of Kathmandu Valley and back up to
go poke and then went over to demon and
he thought up here on the community of
like-minded community and he hated it
there and he ends up going an Indian
yogen to Lhasa because the Indian person
to get along with today when he got
finally got the central to bed he
absolutely hated that place soon and he
spends a lot of poetic ain't talking
about how institutions in center he
finally goes back to treat central
Central retreat center and he reflects
on what Aggies to bed minute he's very
explicit about a mile oh man or our
minds bed and but what he seems to wrap
his identity around most is landscape
it's not so concerned about institutions
he's not so concerned about social
purposes concerned about landscaping so
what he ends up writing most about most
of this boy outfit rapala his balance so
what I like about what you did
collectively attention meetings start to
differ
what I take them thank you we have time
for one last question over here I know
yep well thank you very much you know
there was a question in the Indian
Parliament about six seven years back on
the status of the Tibetans in India
Tibetan refugees in India question was
related to the numbers first the second
was very specific questions whether the
Tibetans have been given the indian
citizenship and not refugees and the
Indian or Minister made a statement to
40 statement there are more than 100,000
Tibetan refugees in India and second was
though they have been though some of
them have been offered citizenship they
would not like to catch the usual but he
made us supplementary statement saying
that but on the on top though they are
not been able there they are not willing
to take citizenship come in the village
extending all the facilities including
education health and all now this is
despite the fact the minister also said
this is despite the fact that the India
has not ratified in 1951 conventions and
B 1967 protocol for the for the info on
the only refugee management now if you
see if you see in in the bar and and the
mark mera statement about materials and
Tibetans in India good years would not
likely like to be Tibetans and Tibetans
would not likely like to be but yes
because let's be very clear about it in
good years KBOO tears are a very clearly
scheduled tribe they have got a clearly
scheduled tribes status in area right
that means they are Indian citizens that
too they are very
civic character that's why there are
several tribes would they get other
facilities other than the normal indian
citizens right whereas in case of nepal
the refugee literature wherever it has
been written not very clear about one
they won and they have not signed the
nepal has not ratified both the 51
convent convention at the 67 protocol on
the other hand they allow the refugees
to come in and settle there but also at
the same time would not extend any sort
of any any rights that is generally
extended to or common citizen right so
there is this all this the present is in
today actually raises whole whole range
of questions about one of their rights
even as simple or to call it refugees
right besides their identity thank you
for that comment I'm sure we could keep
this discussion going for a while let's
take it to the break for the next 15
minutes and the lobby thank you very
much for a wonderful session